what's up guys i'm greg alba and I'm
John Humphrey alright so we're gonna go
into this spoiler talk before we do I
wanted to say a special thank you to
RealD 3d on a very honest note like
completely honest the visual effects in
this film played a lot better in real d3
yeah yeah yeah Scenic's to my girlfriend
Olivia watching this and especially with
a certain villain in case you haven't
realized this is a spoiler talk this is
a spoiler talk there's seven deadly sins
characters in here and I remembered
watching this the first time in 2d and
thinking I looked a little like off but
in he really 3d I was like that looks a
lot better stuff and I found there to be
less floating head syndrome with some of
the Shazam characters yeah yes I think
especially for like the in terms of it
you know like there's a comedy amplified
now it's 3d but it sort of like did the
actual you know action movie moments it
actually really accentuated it a lot so
and the way that just the way the film
is shot and captured in the lenses they
chose and stuff it lends itself well so
yeah if you haven't seen 3d I actually
do sincerely sincerely sincerely
recommend it and II hope Trent we're
gonna do a short spoiler talk about the
movie Shazam this will be uncut
hopefully you don't say anything racist
or sexist like how we normally do when a
camera is not pointed at us we're gonna
just a little bit no good little
experiment here we're just gonna talk
about the big ending stuff first they
win and then we'll go backwards yeah
afterwards let's just talk about the
things that people probably wanted
you're really touched on and you know
it's been kind of like a hectic week for
myself especially in the middle of
moving lost some stuff and if I seem a
tad bit out of it I do apologize and
also if there's things that we end up
not going into where you know we get
those consoles I can't believe you
didn't talk about yeah but give your
thoughts because that's what you really
want is to share your opinion anywho at
the very
this movie they have the Shazam family
moment is Amelie which I if you watch
trailer number two reaction it's exactly
what I guessed because I I did read the
from the pages the new 52 the Jeff Jones
one where they did where they do have
that in there and where Billy is able to
pass along the Shazam power and then his
foster family gets the power of Shazam
yes and IMDB they had actors like DJ
cotrona Anna Brody listen I'm like
that's got to be what they are
yeah oh and to be fair they slipped up
and they listed Megan good as grown up
Darla yeah well the rest of them were
left blank that's true that's true
that's true confirmation so when that
moment happened it was a really cool
moment like this movie has a good handle
of taking care of its cheese just right
yeah you know because in another context
is just could've been very corny but
here it's appropriately family-friendly
cheesy who when it goes down yeah
especially I'd like to say that DJ
cotrona it's like so green yeah silly
yeah but but it was a rewarding moment
and it was it was very cool and
especially in terms of what they do with
the characters they're how like yeah
Billy has found his family he has found
where he belongs and I like the element
as well of how he defeats sivanna with
the seven deadly sins of luring Envy to
come out of him more than just like
we're gonna superhero punch each other a
bunch you know yeah totally speaking of
which I love that moment were there in
the city and then Billy can't hear him I
think that was such a such a great
self-aware joke yeah and such a good
meta joke for what superheroes have
those kind of monologue conversations
back and forth you know
and an appropriate way to undermine some
of the darkness because this is a movie
that does manage to have some of that in
earnest but also it yes ribs on you know
the the broader convention yeah and then
you know the moment where here's where
the movie kind of lost me a tad pulled
me out a tad bit it's when you know they
have this setup of how Freddy and Billy
are looking for a lair you know and then
they find their lair the whole family
finds their lair you see in this is that
really like I have it Oh in the comics
it's different that's not where my issue
comes in I'm just using this as an
explanation for why I found it okay in
the comic and while I'm a little bit
questionable about it here because we
were saw it twice and with a lot this
last time we saw it was about a week and
a half ago so literally the the things
we want to talk about or really are
retain in our mind at this moment you
know we saw it twice we should remember
everything sure we can but this is
really which is so in that the moment
were there at the lair like while it's a
cute family moment well that's a very
adorable family moment the thing that
kind of worries me about Shazam
franchise going forward is in the comics
it's it's very apparent that he
temporarily gives them powers like in a
similar type of scene where seven deadly
sins is causing mayhem and whatnot and
and this is and the family is saving
people's lives and that's another
element that I want to say what I really
like too is that you really get a lot of
time of going see they're saving people
that's just about punching main baddies
yeah they're saving a lot of individuals
and actually interacting with them to
you know yeah so I think for like a
superhero film it brings back that joy
and Wonder of superheroes the thing
though that kind of gets me a little
concerned is do they all have they all
just have the Shazam power down just
indefinitely yeah so like for all Shazam
movies going forward are they all just
gonna have that power
you know cuz what if there's a new
villain who's just one guy and who
doesn't have it looks like they're
building up for mister mine and I
imagine that for part three it might be
black Adam which I think would be a
perfect
a - - Oh Shazam trilogy movie because
mr. Coast adieus is one of his main
villains and he get the seven deadly
sins included which is very appropriate
and then mr. mine who was featured the
other comic I read was a society of evil
monster Society of evil and mr. mind is
a big villain than that and then if you
top it off a part three with the one who
can ultimately match the Sam's Power
Black Adam that would be a great cap off
or like you know maybe before I do more
sure but for like the first three that
would be really really cool plus that's
probably enough time to get the rock
schedule clear enough to shoot it yes I
just think it kind of minimizes the
effect of the standalone Shazam series
if I can you get into part two and yeah
there's like a bunch of Shazam why do we
need a Justice League we got a bunch of
Shazam yeah that one even in I mean it
didn't really bug me during the viewing
experience of the movie but I put me in
retrospective the thought of well going
forward
yeah I think back and it to me it does
at least a smidgen diminished just the
fact that you know it's the Shazam gives
his powers to Billy and that feels like
such a special thing and then he gives
the power to like six other people yeah
really easily and yeah I could just keep
the power and so yeah I don't know it's
not a big issue to me I'm not sitting
you're hanging on hard to it but it is
something that kind of diminishes the
effect a little bit and they didn't go
all right let's all team up and take one
one thing that wasn't fan [ __ ] stick for
were they always like one punch at a
time yeah yeah that's all girl when
they're let's all just team up on
Thaddeus you know you were still just
Billy and Daddy as they kept it at its
core and also another reason why I
really like it is because they have this
whole element running which I found to
be very muchly effective with Freddy
saying you know of course I want these
powers like look at me you know his
jealousy I could like the actor Jack
Dillon grazier is so good in that role
cuz I easily could have been a character
that was annoying or like seeking pity
or something like that but he hits all
the right notes in that in that
performance that when he has that moment
after the whole bus incident that you're
like yeah a toot of court of course you
would feel that way you're the one who's
obsessed with superheroes they're the
one who follows and
studies and his guiding Billy along the
journey of course you're the one who
wants these powers so in terms of like
Shazam powers being instilled I really
like that for Freddy's character more
like the other ones like okay cool
that's cool but for Freddy that's
emotionally rewarding yeah that's why I
find it very effective yeah and it ties
into the greater debate of their
relationship in the movie you know like
your conflict that exists between them
and it makes that you know kind of
stronger yeah and so going forward the
the final ending moment that you know
you do see it with what I think was
great about that like the final moment
like that's know before before the
credits roll boys you know it moves at a
convent movie you're gonna get some
post-credit scenes so the the button of
the movie you know you know that when
Billy forgets to show up I'll be a scene
later where Billy's gonna show up and
it's gonna look really cool for everyone
so when Billy shows up and then he's
like and I brought a friend the first
time we watched it I was the one in the
audience going oh [ __ ] thrown out there
Joe like seems like you see the the
Superman and it is Henry Cavill suit you
know and I probably wasn't Henry cow it
was definitely Henry's devil Henry cuz
like I want to show up for this complete
my picture deal and then the second time
we saw it was a lot of people though and
it's it's really funny especially
because of all the controversy love is
Henry Cavill Superman or not it's it
seems like he's not but it's not exactly
confirmed people are saying he still
wants the place it really it wasn't like
there hasn't been some official leave
like the way how Ben Affleck has just
made it official like you know and Henry
Cavill it seems like this weird muddy
territory and like this suit though yeah
keep it perfectly cheeky and it really
fits the tone of the movie too because
it's it's like such a comical angle and
he just steps into frame with his head
yeah yeah yeah it's perfect cuz it's
like it addresses in a subtle way the
fact that we have no idea what's going
to permit so there yeah it's almost less
distracting in a way
because you've got the laugh combined
with the fact that it's Superman you
know like it that's all we need to focus
on is that Supes showed up to bring him
dessert you know I heard one thing of
how some people think there's there's a
moment where they're fighting Thaddius
and billy and in the city and there's a
kid playing with toys a Batman and
Superman toy and he drops them and
something that some people thought like
that could be theorizing that
foreshadowing that yeah they're not
going to deal with Batman Superman
anymore but I don't think that's the
case especially because you have the
Superman ending cameo right there you
know Superman with Shazam and and then
and then and then mid-credits scene you
you get a hint at we like the I we
touched on with a mr. mind and he has
some type of like voice box speaker yeah
interdimensional translator or something
I'm not entirely sure how I feel about
that
like I think the idea of mr. my being
here is cool and the tone they've
established with the Shazam movie you
can have mr. mind working here because
the concept of mr. mind is kind of silly
especially when you think alike some
word but you know it can it can sound
really cool see yeah but but for what
this Shazam movie has done it actually
works you you could fathom it working I
guess is it just gonna be a dude who's
like my controlling Thaddeus again
because even though Thaddeus had a
motive and he was already a very
specific person who identified himself
as being someone who's a villain and
evil before the seven deadly sins
inhabited his body there seem to already
be some type of mind control
manipulation thing happening with him so
I'm like it's just gonna be more of that
with Thaddeus just with less powers you
know or different powers yeah like
because I don't really know I know
there's been several different
interpretations not only of Billy Batson
and Shazam but also if fatty is sivanna
as well and in the new 52 that Geoff
Johns wrote and he know he was heavily
involved in the creative producing
process of this one I did he write this
I don't think he wrote this one did he
no he did not
okay so the the the creative process
evolved with her you know at Thaddius in
the comic that I had the one that really
sticks in my mind is he has a goal of
uncovering the tomb of Black Adam
learning the powers of Shazam and
everything because he wants to save his
family I don't think they ever specified
specifically what's going on with his
family it sounded more like a wife and
kids situation than it did a father
brother thing yeah you know he ain't
saving those dudes yes but I feel like
there's like emotional complexity to
explore with Thaddius going forward with
this story you know so when it would be
nice to bring a character like that back
also and she sure of eloping them you
know in the seven deadly sins i I
thought they were fine in the movie you
know like I think their highlight scene
is easily the boardroom scene yeah you
know the the boardroom moment was was
surprisingly more scary than I expected
it to be like what it first shot like
whoa I guess I guess do you see has not
completely can the whole Dorothy yeah
like this is really dark actually for
his whimsical as this movie isn't
fantastical in certain respects I
thought they anchored their dark pretty
well true absolutely and my issue would
the seven deadly sins my oh my only real
complaint is I I didn't feel their
distinctions yeah you know like when
Billy is listing off the seven deadly
sins when it before he pulls out Envy
from from Thaddius I was like wow you
know honestly I couldn't tell you who
was there up coasted interacting with
them and fighting with their much more
in the visual motifs it's like oh greed
I guess has multiple arms so you can
grab a lot of stuff like yeah but yeah
ultimately they are just kind of big
monsters that destroy stuff you know how
like in the x-men comics they all have
like distinguished suits and then in the
movies they give them all black leather
that's kind of what I feel kind of
looked at saying yeah yeah and we don't
really get to see you do much that
demonstrates your specific you know sin
yeah exactly that was like a Miss
they're all kind of seem to serve the
same purpose of that big imposing strong
you know yeah I mean the only one who
really does anything kind of different
and it's only literally in the
background of a shot cuz it reminded me
of Full Metal Alchemist is gluttony has
like a big mouths body that opens yeah
and so I assume he could eat people but
that's that's it and I like the
inclusion I do like the the rewrite of
how
being or the adaptation version of this
of the seven deadly sins it happening
Savannah because in the in the comic I
read at least it it was actually mr.
brighter the bride there's the prior
kids the bullies and they play such a
big part in the journey and they end up
inhabitable father of there's mr. briar
and in that you see starts like in this
movie they're all being contained in the
rock of eternity but they're actually
they're their souls were spread out in
the city and they all think they're a
different human being they don't realize
they're a seven they're a realize
they're one of the seven deadly sins
itself atius and Black Adam are forcing
them to realize that oh here's who they
really are so they all form it's like
giant crazy they like kind of like you
know Power Rangers when they've morph
into one as well that's what they do is
they all Norfolk today all the
distinguished personality all more
megazor and for the movie I don't think
it could have probably wort here but I
do think that the movie could have also
benefitted from making them very
distinguished yeah it's like I like the
handling of them and I thought that
David Sandberg horror inclinations
helped those to be it's just imposing
and cool to look at but yeah I given
that the seven deadly sins is well-worn
and pretty rich you know motif to borrow
from I I agree oh I wish they had used
it yeah except for being like a cool
mythological thing yeah and you do get a
slight black atom cameo it's when it
says executive produced by Dwayne
Johnson but when the wizard is
explaining to Billy specifically and you
got the embers and explaining the
history of the seventies yeah that guy
is black Adam right there so I thought
very smart way to tease yeah you know
yeah because I was predicting that oh I
bet that post-credit scenes gonna be the
tomb of black yeah that's for sure what
its gonna be and no we don't get that
but that's still an appropriate hint
because it links to the whole lineage of
why the wizard is in the position he is
and now
yeah why he's very specific about who
he's choosing it effortlessly feels like
a part of this movie also alluding to a
potential other movie yeah yeah yeah I
can't wait for that and also there's a
you know a cool a couple Tiger reference
Billy has a backpack of one thing I'm on
point I was like Billy has a backpack
that's a tiger on it there's a moment
where he gives the little girl a tiger
toy to calm her down and that's the toy
he wants as a child himself and both
yeah exactly and both comics that I read
there's a relationship that he has with
it with a tiger and like especially in
the latter one I read it was he there's
a tiger at the zoo who eventually he
does use sea power to who makes that
crazy villain his tiger why is a not a
villainous tiger but a way to help him
fight he's like your tiger yeah to help
him fight at one point it's like very
brief but basically because Billy
there's this whole storyline here where
he's looking for his family his mom
specifically but in this story lines
that I read he he doesn't have a family
and but the tiger is the closest thing
he has to remembering his family because
he would visit the tiger at the zoo you
know so I thought that was it I thought
that was yeah I thought that was an
appropriate nod to to those elements I
guess you know there's also the
post-credits scene of the actual
post-credit scene you know where they do
their umpteenth Aquaman reference most
famous movie that we hope will make more
money by referencing it a lot in this I
love how Freddy wears clothes that are
the movie logos of these guys you know
honestly I found that distracting I
truly did I was like ah cute Aquaman but
why is that the same Aquaman on the
posters the ice is the same thing with
Batman and Wonder Woman Batman toys are
even like the enemy yeah Bob Kane died
Bob Kane of Kevin Conroy yeah yeah Kevin
Conroy
see that I was more okay with cuz I was
like at least this isn't your current DC
EU iconography but you know it was funny
I actually also thought and
just spitballing like random thoughts
here that's why I want to get the big
stuff out III thought it was pretty
fascinating
they have like kind of two nods in one I
can't tell if the second one is an
actual nod to something or but for sure
the first one is obviously a not too big
when they're fighting in the store oh
the piano and the piano yeah that's her
big reference like because they've
already said that tonally they wanted to
borrow from big in which they did is my
head so yeah make a direct reference
there but there was something about the
moment where Billy gets hit through the
window
oh the glass falls down that I felt like
I was watching Terminator 2 again
hahaha the Galleria when Arnold flies
through there falls exactly like that
he sort of seems like he's being hunted
by a terminator ESCA like yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't know if that's an actual
nod or I just flash to that at this
point whenever we find these things I'm
like I've assumed yes we all love those
movies from the 80s and 90s yeah that's
fair that's fair I guess they're the
other thing too that I think could have
been a little bit more affect I'm in
such cross dressing this twice and I'm
at such crossroads with how Savannah
storyline was ultimately handled because
what I thought was great was super
effective was after he catches the bus
Billy when he makes that mistake of
hitting the buses tire and he catches
the bus and then everyone's around him
and stuff it's going great and then you
see Savannah appear in the background
the first time I watched it and the
second time I watch it with a crowd who
was most of them were watching it the
first time was like everyone's going
like oh she we get Savannah had have
been in the movie for a while yeah it's
like that just reminded now you're like
oh god yeah [ __ ] he's here it's like
it's not like the movie makes you forget
that he's in the movie in the right way
you're not in the like oh this is so
poorly structured worse of an event yeah
exactly like I he's a lackluster it
wasn't that effect it was it was the
effect
like they intentionally wanted you to
forget about him for a while not to
expect him to show up now yeah or to
because he just saved a bunch of people
and this is not the time you'd expect
him early on in the movie to show up
first because you've been so engrossed
in the whole how Billy wants to you know
just do his own thing he wants to stain
shows am form him and Freddie are having
a lot of friction with each other
you're so engrossed in that by the time
that he shows up it's so effective but
the thing is that I had some issues with
is like I I really really appreciated
the the writing intention and aspect of
especially starting this movie uh-huh
like oh this is all like Savannah
origins right here you know of why he is
the way he is I prologue I just found it
a little bit cuz you got the villain
side of Savannah who feels like from a
comic book and it feels very cartoony
like the dad and the brother who were
just like super bullies you know so bolt
like just to the degree we were like I
don't really believe this Oh like it's
so up there and then you have this one
very realistic abandonment story yeah of
like so you got Savannah with a parental
problem with his dad and you got Billy
with a parental problem with his mom and
one side of the story feels very
realistic and the other side feels so
much like a cartoon and and so like
honestly like the book when the
boardroom scene happened it was cool but
sometimes we check in with Savannah I
kind of felt like it slowed down some of
the excitement and fun flavor of the
film well because he's got such a
personal motivation but there's not
enough flesh on his storyline and the
characters that inhabit it to really
bring that home so it just does feel
like comic book villainy whereas like
when Billy reunites with his mom that's
a whole emotional scene I gotta say I
love the way they execute that because
when you see that first moment where the
way Billy remembers that moment going
down of it's like he remembers the
moment going down and but when you watch
that moment you're like what his mom
like how come she just forgot it I I
didn't even think
gosh I didn't think she intentionally
abandon him even though everyone around
him is telling him she abandoned him he
I did not think I didn't think that's
what was the case so I was like how she
just lose him you know I wondered but I
didn't expect me to go there and then
when you do the moms perspective it's
the same exact scene just in a different
tone yeah same dialogue just different
kind of deliveries how I saw that day
yeah like he remembers it that way from
the perspective of a child but she
remembers it totally differently yeah
with all those others yes they were on
her mind I thought and that's what I
mean like that's so realistic so well
told and the execution of that whole
scene is very heartbreaking for Billy
and I like how that becomes the push for
him to go no I have a real family now so
I like that emotional thing so I really
I really respect the way they handle the
flashback of it both of the way they
told that same scene twice in a
different way and so subtle and in a
weird way I also loved the little motif
of the compass and that he gives it to
her and she doesn't like what it is I
think you might need this though and and
and somehow that felt like a nice
poignant little button to put on that
yeah yeah yeah you know like III really
enjoy this movie like everyone the whole
cast in this movie is great the foster
family is wonderful it's a lot of fun
it's got a good mixture of tones it's
really punchy it's pretty well paced
yeah and I I actually think it played a
little bit funny enough it's not played
better on the second viewing yeah but
yeah guys anything we missed anything
you think we should talk about comment
below you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and yeah hi Lee do you recommend
checking out this film RealD 3d see you
guys